hey everyone welcome back now let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve a pretty hard problem
regular expression matching so we are
given an
input string s and a pattern or a
regular expression
p and we want to implement regular
expression matching
and these are the two special characters
that we're gonna have to worry about
a period and a star so the stars or so
the period will match
to any particular character and the star
basically means that any character that
comes before it can be repeated
zero times or it can be repeated
infinite times right so it can be
repeated as many times as it needs to be
and the match or the pattern has to
cover the entire input string so it has
to match
the full input string so one example
is let's say so these are the special
characters we worry about right the
period
and the star if we don't have either of
them then it's basically
string matching right so we see in this
example we have
two a's right that's one input string
and a single a so basically do these
strings match each other they
don't match each other so we have to
return false
meaning that the input string s does not
match this regular expression
and remember it's only going to be a
regular expression which possibly has
the star
or possibly has the period now imagine
instead if our pattern
was a period so in that case
we would compare it to the string double
a and we would see that yes they do
match because remember the period can be
any character so we could
say okay we'll given this pattern this
could be double a so
it would match this input string what if
we were checking does it match
this input string a b in that case it
would also match because this period
could then turn into a b
so it would be a b and these two match
each other
but of course if we had a period period
checking if it matches double a it
doesn't because they're not even the
same length this has
three this has two there's no way we
could put any characters for these two
periods that would match
double a and what about this second
example let's say the input string
is double a and the pattern is a star
so what this star means is a star
so a star basically means that the
element that comes before
this a could be repeated multiple times
or zero times so
the possible strings that this pattern
could match to could be
an empty string because this character
could be repeated
zero times right so empty string this
character could be repeated once
so a single a this character could be
repeated twice
so double a this character could be
repeated three times so
aaa and so on and so on right we could
repeat this a infinite number of times
but if you take a look at our input
string we're only checking does it match
double a of course it does right we just
repeat the a
twice so in this case we return true
a third example so let's say our input
string is a b
and we're checking does it match the
pattern dot star
so basically what this dot star means is
we could have
a string that's empty right repeating
the dot zero time so empty string
uh we could repeat the dot once so dot
we could repeat it twice double dot
right and so on and so on and
so let's say this right double dot is
what we're looking for we're checking
does
this match a b well one of the dots
could be
a and one of the dots could be b so that
matches
double dot so this would return true
so as you can see that there's probably
going to be a few edge cases we have to
deal with right
the complexity really mainly comes from
the star the dot isn't so difficult
right
but the star makes things interesting so
let's just try to brute force this let's
look at one example
this example let's say this is our
string s and
this is our pattern a star so as you
know the star
is really where the complexity comes
from so let's make a decision tree let's
brute force this
so this is the string we're trying to
match to this is our pattern a star
we know so we're first gonna look at the
first a
and then we're gonna look at the first
character of this now
this isn't just an ordinary character
there's a star that comes after it so
this could be repeated
zero times or more times right so let's
brute force this
we know we have a choice are we gonna
repeat the a
at least once or are we gonna repeat it
zero times if we repeat it zero times
then we
end up with an empty string right if we
repeat it once
we end up with a single a now clearly we
want the single
a because it matches this right
and if we decided to to have an empty
string meaning we want this star to
or and this character a to repeat zero
times then we would have to
move to this position right and there
clearly
isn't any character here maybe there
would be a b maybe there would be
an a but there's clearly nothing there
so this is this
decision is going to stop right we
cannot go any farther
all we can do here is an empty string
but it's okay because we ended up
matching with this a when we were on
this
path right so now the character we're
looking to match in the input string is
this
single a so now again we have a choice
are we gonna repeat the star like in
this
spot we repeated the star and this we
didn't repeat the star
now again we have that choice are we
going to repeat the star or are we
not going to repeat the star if we don't
repeat the star we're going to end up
with a
single a and then we're gonna have to be
shifted over to this position meaning we
cannot use the star anymore
so we're gonna stop right this is going
to be our string a single a
but you can see in our input our input
string was a double a
so really our other decision where we do
repeat the star at least one more time
is gonna lead us to
double a and that's good because now we
have the second a meaning we matched
this second a right so now in reality we
have matched
the input string but just to show you in
theory we could
keep going we could decide not to use
the star anymore right we would be
shifted to that position
and in which case our ending string
would just be double a or we could use
the star
one more time meaning we'd get triple a
but then of course you can see we're
even bigger than the input string that
we wanted to match so we stop
but we see that we did end up finding
the results since we
found the result right we found the
input string
that means that these do match right so
we would return
true because the input string matches
the regular expression but as you can
see
we're doing a decision tree this is not
exactly going to be super efficient
right
how many decisions are we going to have
well any time we get to a star
we're going to have two different
decisions how many times can we repeat
that decision it's going to be
n where n is the input string
s so clearly you can tell this is not
super efficient
but in case you haven't noticed this is
a dynamic programming problem and if we
take this
and we implement a cache then we can get
this time complexity down
to n squared or in other words really
we're getting it down to
n times m where n is the length
of the input string and m is the length
of
the pattern and this is if we do the top
down
memoization with a cache we can also do
the actual
bottom up dynamic programming solution
so the bottom up dynamic programming
solution
and both of these actually have the same
time time complexity so i'm going to
show you the top down coding solution
but once you know the top down solution
getting the bottom up full dynamic
program solution
is not usually impossible but before
that let's look at one more example
so the index i'm going to use so let's
say this
is our input string s and this is our
pattern p so i'm going to use two
variables to keep track of where we are
in each of the strings i'm going to use
i to tell us where we're at in the input
string i'm going to use
j to tell us where we're at in the
pattern so
remember whenever we reach a character
that has a star that comes after
we have two choices so i'm going gonna
draw our decision tree
we have a choice to use the star
or we have a choice to not use the star
so in this case if we use the star
meaning we use the character at least
once we're gonna get a c right we're
gonna repeat the c
just once if we don't do that we're
gonna
get an empty string so i'll just draw
this dash for empty string now you can
see we have a c
but the first character of our input
string is a
so really what we want to do is not use
this c any times meaning we do not want
to use the star we don't want
to repeat c even a single time
so the decision we want is not this
decision but this
is the path that's going to lead us to
the correct answer
so what am i going to do with this j
pointer i'm going to shift
j so i'm going to shift j over here
right so notice what we just did in this
path where we do not use the
star right we didn't use the star what
did we do
we ended up shifting j by two so we
took j and then added two to it that's
very important because any time we
choose
not to use the star we're gonna take our
pointer where it's at and then shift it
twice because we're shifting one to get
to the next character but also look at
the star we don't want to land
on the star we want to land at the next
character
and what about pointer i are we going to
shift that well since we didn't use the
star that means we weren't
able to match with the character a right
so actually i
is going to stay exactly where it is
so in this decision what we did is we
left i
the exact same and then we took j and
added
2 to it and this is very important
because this is exactly what i'm going
to do
in the code so i remains the same j
plus 2. okay so now we're still at this
a but our j is over here so notice how
j right after j is a star that means
this character a can
can be repeated zero times or it can be
repeated one or more times
so again we have a decision to make so
one decision is we use the star at least
once the other decision is we do not use
the star at all
so if we use the star once we'll get a
string of
a if we don't use the star again we'll
end up with an
empty list or an empty string so
remember when we used the star over here
we got a c that didn't match the a but
now we actually have
an a that exactly matches the character
over here right
but what about this path right right now
we have an empty string
is this path gonna lead us to the
correct answer well the only way to find
out would be to continue on this
decision tree right making decisions
and stuff but i'm not going to show that
because it's going to get pretty messy
and you can tell by looking at the
string since we chose this path we would
have to
leave i as it is and we'd have to add 2
to j
so i would stay here j would be moved
over here and then you see the pattern
left at this point is just b does that
match the input string s it definitely
does not
right so clearly this decision is not
going to lead us to the correct answer
but let's look at this this is promising
let's continue on this path so
so if we end up using the star as we did
right now how are we going to update our
pointers well take a look at i
we matched a exactly what we wanted to
do
right so what are we going to do with i
well we're allowed to shift it by 1 now
so we're going to take i and move it
over here right we already matched
this character we don't really need to
match it again
but we do need to match the remaining
string of s
a and b what about j well j
can stay the same because we use the
star once we repeated this
a once now we can continue to repeat it
or we can repeat it zero times
and we can make that decision by rem by
leaving
j exactly where it is so when we go down
this path
when we actually use the star what we're
going to do is add one to i
but leave j exactly as it is and this is
important too
these two things are important because
this is exactly what i'm going to do
when i write the code
so since we're still at j and there's
still is a star
that comes after it we again have two
choices so we can choose again
to repeat this a or we can choose
to not repeat the a so if we repeat the
a
then we're gonna get the string double a
right
and if we choose not to repeat a then
we're gonna have a single
a and then meaning we're not gonna use
this anymore and then we're gonna have a
b that comes
after right and you can tell a b by
itself
does not match the entire input string
right so clearly
this is not going to be the solution but
you can see that the new character we
just added the single a
it matches exactly what we were looking
for another
a right so that means we can repeat what
we just did
up here we can take this i and shift it
by one
and we can leave j exactly where it is
so now i is at the last character in s
and i was shifted by one and j remained
the same
okay i'm starting to run out of space
but let's see if we can finish this
again we're at this position where star
comes after right j
is over there so we have two choices we
can
use the star or we can not use the star
if we use the star we're going to get
triple a
right and see the third a it does not
match the character that we're currently
at b so clearly
this is not going to be the decision we
go down
if we don't match the a then we're going
to end up
with a double a right exactly what we
had before
right but in this case as we usually do
when we
don't use the star what we're going to
end up doing is taking i
leaving it where it is because we know
we didn't match this character right now
but we're going to take
j and add 2 to it and since
we add 2 to j that means we have to
shift it by two so now j
is going to be at the last character in
p at the b
and notice how j now the character after
there's no
star that comes after right so we
actually don't have a
choice right now we are only checking
does the character at j this b
does it match the character at i this
other b
we don't have a choice because there's
no star we're not allowed to repeat this
b
zero times or one time or three times we
have to use it
only a single time right we must use it
we're required to use this b
but lucky for us we have a b right here
right so we don't have a choice right
now
we're just checking do they match and
they do so
what we're going to do now is see that
our string that we created with our
regular expression
is now a a and
b right and that matches what we wanted
to
in the input string but it's important
to note
when we do not have a star we're
strictly checking do the characters
equal we're checking does s of i
equal p of
j and if they do equal what we're gonna
do
how are we gonna update our pointers i
and j we're gonna take
i add one to it and take
j add one to it we're going to do this
in the code
so now when you see if we take our i and
then
shift it over here so i'm just going to
make a barrier between these two and if
we take our j
and shift it by one you see both of
these
are out of bounds right i is out of
bounds
and j is out of bounds that's how you
know we have
perfectly matched so really when we say
that
i is greater than or equal to the length
of s meaning it's out of bounds and
j is greater than or equal to
the length of p that's how you know they
have matched exactly perfectly
but my question is what if i wasn't
was i was still in bounds but what if j
was out of bounds what if j was greater
than or equal to the length of
p so an example would be this let's say
our input string was
a a right that's our input string our
pattern
is a is just a single a right let's say
our
our index of i was here let's say our
index of
j was over here right clearly this does
not match this is our string s this is
our pattern p
this does not match this right
so basically if only j is out of bounds
then they do not match because we still
have some string
in the input that hasn't been matched
but
what if the opposite was true what if i
was out of bounds right i
is out of bounds so i is greater than
the length of
s but j was still in bounds what does
that look like
an example would be this let's say we
had an input of
a and let's say our pattern was
a star and b star
so let's say our index of i was shifted
by one so our i
is over here and we took our j starting
over here
we matched the a a single time then we
shifted our j
to be at this b character so basically
i'm asking so with our i over here and
our j
over here do these two strings match
each other
technically yes right because this b
could be repeated
zero times and still match
the input a so just because i is out of
bounds
doesn't mean we have to return false but
as i just showed a second ago
if the j happens to be out of bounds so
if the j
is out of bounds then we must return
false i know this is probably a little
confusing with these edge cases
but i hope the examples make it clearer
and i hope the code that i'm about to
show you makes it even more clear
so again i'm going to do the top down
memoization dynamic programming solution
not the bottom
up i think the top down is easier to
understand when you're first starting
this problem just doing the bottom up
solution
is more confusing in my opinion but we
are going to do this
recursively so i'm going to do a nested
function depth first search inside
of our uh is match function i guess you
could call this backtracking or you
could call it
uh whatever else you wanted i'm just
going to call it dfs
and we're passing in i and j which are
going to tell us what position we're at
in the input string s for i and j is
going to tell us where we're at in the
input string p
so as always with recursive functions
let's start with the base case i just
showed you that if
i is out of bounds and j is out of
bounds that means we have found
our solution that means we were able to
match the pattern to the string so we
can return true
but as i showed you if i is not out of
bounds but
j is out of bounds we have some string
in s
that we haven't matched and there's no
way we're going to be able to match it
so we have to return
false so these are our two base cases
notice
that given these two cases it's still
possible that
i could be out of bounds right i
technically could be out of bounds
and neither of these return statements
would execute right because
this needs i and j to be out of bounds
so
we would pass this and we would pass
this and i could still be out of bounds
but i'm going to show you how i'm going
to handle that right now
so the first thing we want to check is
is there a match
between the first character so
is there a match between s of i
and p of j and the other thing we could
check
technically right p of j could have
a period in that position meaning the
period matches to
any character right so we have to check
this or check this
and since we know i could technically be
out of bounds before we even
check this we have to confirm that i is
inbound so i is less than the length of
s so strictly less than not less than
equal so
if these conditions are satisfied that
means the first character
of each string matches exactly the
reason i'm putting this in a variable is
we're gonna have to repeat it a couple
times in the following code
so the first thing i want to check is
does the
following character in uh the pattern
string so p
of j plus one does it match the star
is it a star and the reason i'm checking
this first is because the star has the
highest precedence and i'm checking j
plus one because we know the pattern the
first character in the pattern string is
never going to be a star and since i'm
checking p
of j plus one i have to first check that
j plus one
is inbound so i have to check that it's
less than the length of
p so if this is true that means we're
gonna have to
we're gonna have to take care of this
star right and
we remember when we encounter a star we
have two choices so i'm going to do a
recursive call right
that first search the first choice we
have
is don't use the star right if we
don't use the star we leave i as it is
and we take
j and add two to it right that's one
now we know we have two choices if
either of them evaluates to true
then we can return true right we're
brute forcing this right now
so the other decision we have is the
other decision we have
is use the star right so if we use the
star
that means we can take i and add one to
it
and we can leave j where it is but
remember we can
only use the star if there's a match
between
the first character right the first two
characters right because we only want to
use the star if there happens to be a
match
so really here we're checking if there's
a match
and this whole thing about this
recursive call evaluates to true right
so i'm going to wrap this
in parentheses so basically what i'm
saying
is these are our two choices this is one
recursive call and this is another
recursive call if either of these
evaluates to true then we can return
true and that's what i'm doing basically
by putting these
on the same line so i don't know the
best way to format this
maybe this is somewhat readable
so if either of these is true we're
going to end up returning true if
neither of them is true we're going to
return false so this
by itself this these three lines of code
handles
that star for us now if this isn't true
meaning we don't have a star
character then we're looking just for a
simple match right so we can just
check if match if the two characters
match
then what are we gonna do well remember
we can then
increment i by one and we can increment
j
by one and return the result of that
now if there's not a star and the
characters don't match
in that case it's simple right then we
can just return false meaning that this
string will never match the pattern so
then we return false
and this is the brute force solution
it's actually as simple
as that so let's let's return it and let
me show you how
inefficient it is right now so we can
call our debt for search
starting at zero in both of the strings
oops i had a syntax error so we had
double equal over here we have to put
double
equal over here oops and one last thing
when you have multi-line stuff in python
you have to wrap it all in parentheses
so i'm just going to wrap this entire
thing in parentheses
hopefully it's still readable and a
third bug so i don't know why i checked
if j
is out of bounds of string s when j
refers to the
index of string p so sorry about these
bugs
but okay so this time it finally worked
you can see it's not
super efficient right it took about i
think this is 1.3 seconds
and it was 11 so we did the top we did
the brute force solution but look i
forgot to do the memoization right so
let's
actually do the caching now and make
this efficient so i'm going to create a
cache
it's going to be a hash map so before we
do anything
whenever we call this function we're
first going to check if i
if the pair i j has already been added
to our cache
if it has then we can return it right so
this is going to
basically not have to is basically going
to take care of repeated work for us if
we
execute this we're not going to have to
do all the repeated work but now we
actually have to use this cache so
instead of returning this right away you
can see down here i'm going to actually
take this and add it
to the cache so at index ij
i'm going to put the value that this
returns to
and after that after we add it to the
cache
then i'm going to return it and i'm
going to do the exact same thing
down here so adding this
to the cache and then we can take this
and return it so we're all we're doing
right now is caching
the work that we do so we don't have to
repeat it lastly down here we can
say in the cache add
false and then return false so basically
by just adding what
like four or five lines of code we've
added the caching element to this
function it was pretty easy so taking
the brute force to the
optimal solution was actually pretty
easy and look at the result
look how much faster this is 44
milliseconds
81 so we actually didn't even
need to do the bottom up dynamic
programming solution right
and this i will be honest with you is
not the prettiest way to write this code
i've seen solutions that are a lot
better than this but i really hope that
you
at least were able to understand what
we're doing right
the the meat of the work is done
in this call right basically these
two lines of code are the work that
we're doing right this is where we're
handling the star
case and you can see it's actually not
that difficult right
all we're doing is i stays the same j
added two
or i plus one j stays the same right and
you
understand why we're doing it like that
from the picture that i drew
but i encourage you to do the dynamic
programming solution i'll probably
link the code for that in the
description and i hope this was helpful
if you enjoyed please like and subscribe
it supports the channel a lot
and i'll hopefully see you pretty soon